I don't have a strong opinion
hly yeah um fans of the show will know
we've been doing so much content on
active inference recently so Factor
graphs and variational inference and so
on but um but you know just putting
things in perspective though the last 10
years have been all about the Deep
learning Revolution well what I do think
is we need something else that pure deep
learning isn't the answer and so we're
going to have to bring something into
the mix obviously there's going to be
some form of reinfor for M learning
probably with rewards it's going to have
to be brought into the mix if you want
to build something more intelligent
interesting um what format that will
take I don't know I don't necessarily
see why it would be probabilistic
graphical models this is just a way to
factorize a probability distribution in
an interesting way so to make progress
to that you'd have to tell me which
probability distribution we should be
factorizing and why